great paper today fellow Scholars stable
diffusion XL turbo why well because
today we have these amazing computer
games and simulations that run quickly
and we measure this in frames per second
then we have Offline simulations that
run much slower in seconds per frame and
today we have an AI technique that we
can measure in cats per second you can
create so many cats per second and it
can do this too and surprisingly it may
even help us train self driving cars
will look into that and there's more you
can also try this new tool right now and
we will talk about this amazing
technique too you can also try this for
free too how cool is that so what was
this cat thing this is stable diffusion
XL turbo a supposedly quicker version of
stable diffusion the popular open-source
text to image AI the original version
can do absolutely amazing things but it
takes a bit about 20 to 60 seconds for
an image and this depends on this
setting the number of sampling steps we
typically need 20 to 50 steps to create
a high quality image the more steps the
more computation we have to do and thus
the longer we have to wait and here is
an amazing new paper that promises what
can that really be one to four sampling
steps often in a single step that sounds
incredible I mean if this was true we
would be able to perform text to image
in real time yes real time but wait a
second this is not new creating an image
in one to4 sampling steps has never
never been a problem you can do it
anytime you want with stable diffusion
but unfortunately then you get this a
blurry image no detail so why is this
interesting dear fellow Scholars this is
2minute papers with
Dr well it is interesting because this
new paper allows you to create images
quickly but also at the same time give
you high quality images now let's have a
look at the new
technique wow that is as fast as you can
type the results update almost
immediately and no more blurry images
wow so how quick is it well hold on to
your papers fellow Scholars because it
can create an image in 9 to 10
milliseconds yes there is 100 cats per
second the resolution is 512 x 512 and
the quality is is not bad at all it
typically loses only against a slower
version of itself ASD XL but SD XL has
been surpassed by a new text to image
technique yes we will have a look at
that too in a moment so quality check
mark But following your prompts closely
is also super important and in that area
check mark to excellent and there is so
much more here it can also perform not
only text to image but image to image
translation one image goes in and it
comes out transformed we have seen this
in stable diffusion before and this
helps you Unleash Your creativity like
never before remember this earlier
Nvidia paper where you could draw a
landscape and it would almost
immediately give you a nearly
photorealistic image now it can do that
too and not only with landscape images
but with Apple's memojis too I love the
quick iteration speed here and in fact
people are already using it out there in
the wild let's see how here you see an
incredible example of realtime urban
planning prototyping and visualization
and you can even create animations with
it all this for free and open source so
how is this even possible it is possible
through a technique called adversarial
diffusion distillation luckily we have
the paper with a detailed description of
the phenomenon so here's how you do it
first train a complex diffusion model
this starts out from a noisy image then
over time it learns to reorganize this
noise into an image that depicts our
text prompt but it does this slowly
let's call it the teacher model now
comes the magic we now create a a
smaller student model that tries to
mimic its teacher it learns how the
teacher behaves and tries to reproduce
Its Behavior but wait we already have
the teacher model so why copy it well we
are copying it with the student neural
network so we retain the quality but at
the same time this student network will
be much cheaper and faster so more
corgis and cats cheaper and and faster
now hold on to your papers fellow
Scholars because perhaps this could also
be used to train self-driving course how
well look at this cool new paper from
Nvidia where they use real driving logs
to analyze previous situations and even
create new ones now here all of these
agents are controlled by nvidia's Ai and
are you thinking what I am thinking oh
yes just imagine putting this in into an
imageo image translator AI two more
papers down the line and Bam you have a
simulation where you can safely train
your cars in challenging situations that
actually happened or may happen imagine
this in a similar manner to this earlier
work where we can go from video game
Graphics to real life and back but this
time with real driving situations who
and this new paper can tokenize
trajectories mean meaning that it breaks
down complex driving situations much
like you would break down a sentence
into words and then letters and it does
it very very well how well look it is
able to create more lifelike scenarios
outperforming many many previous
techniques it's like a mini video game
with intelligent AI players what a time
to be alive now as promised we are going
to have a look at this new text to image
AI that L at 1.1 billion images and
learned to create incredibly high
quality outputs for your tax proms you
can try it here the link is available in
the video description so how good is it
well let's test it against stable
diffusion XEL look at that approximately
six to seven times out of 10 it is
preferred over sdxl I think that is
insane don't forget sdxl is a paper that
came out approximately five months ago
and it has already been surpassed Bravo
and while we are looking at some of
these eye popping beautiful images just
imagine that two more papers down the
line and I am sure that we are going to
be looking at images and videos of these
created in real time and all you need to
provide is just a text prompt experiment
tracking model evaluation and production
monitoring for your deep learning
projects and llm apps this is what
weights and biases does and it is the
best everyone is using it try it out now
at
wbme SLP papers or click the link in the
description below